grant shouts transport secretary joining
us now mr shouts uh good morning good of
you to join us this morning uh what's
your advice to motorists at the pump
today
um advice would be carry on as normal
and that's what bp are saying as well um
they describe it on the average day that
they have a handful
of petrol stations that they have to
close out of 12 or 1300 and the
problem's not new there's been a lack of
drivers
actually for many months through this
pandemic because as your report just
said
during the lockdown drivers couldn't be
passed through their lorry hev tests and
that's what's led to this problem
but many more tests are being made
available now
so we should see it smooth out
fairly quickly uh not according to the
rhode haulage association they say it's
another year of um angst
yeah there's a difference between um
the this specific issue in the very
short term and the much longer term uh
issues because in fact in point of fact
i was talking to the the chief executive
of uh the largest uh rhode haulage uh uh
organization logistics uk i think he
said he's been in the job for five years
and the very first thing on his desk was
the shortage of lorry drivers and it's
never gone away and that said most
people won't have ever noticed that so
there's a difference between what is a
systemic shortage which we want to deal
with but also the shorter term problem
people not having been able to take
their tests during coronavirus for
understandable reasons and the number of
new tests that we've now made available
by doubling the supply of those tests
uh it would be disingenuous to say
that's the only reason
um well kovid is the main reason it's a
global problem and um europe has hit
particularly bad uh we've got for
example in germany a 60 000 shortage in
poland a 123 000 shortage of lorry
drivers um so it is as i said is the the
principal cause of the problem and we're
working very hard to change it including
changing the laws in order to provide
more tests for uh hgv drivers and
encouraging people to come back into the
into the market but you're right there
are longer term problems which is it's a
difficult uh a long day's work it's a
hard work it's a skilled job and
actually it's been underpaid up until
now so we very much welcome the salaries
going up the wages going up and that's
attracting more people back to the
sector a quick fix would be short-term
visa for drivers in europe to come to
the uk
i'll look at everything and we'll move
to heaven and earth to do whatever we
can to
make sure that shortages are alleviated
with hgv drivers but we need to look at
the things which are going to make a
difference and the big problem is that
the the testing of drivers coming in you
get an attrition rate people retire if
you can't get new people in and we we
were unable to test 40 000 drivers
during coronavirus that's the principal
um problem uh and of course there are
already six million eu nationals with
settled and pre-settled status some of
whom will already be eligible to to
drive
enticing them to come here is really a
higher salary
and we just need to make sure that the
tests can be passed if people have
perhaps have an expired license but want
to get back to driving a lorry
move heaven and earth to get them to
come here reports this morning in the
newspapers that the environment
secretary wants uh these visas for
skilled workers to um have a short-term
visa for lorry drivers from europe you
and the home secretary do not is there
any truth in that story
no actually we're one on this i think
he's actually talking about the seasonal
workers um schemes specifically and as i
said i wouldn't rule out doing something
or you know any of the measures that are
possible to take for lorry drivers my
point is that over a long period of time
what we've done in this country is rely
on importing cheap european often
eastern european labor undercutting the
domestic market and creating more
long-term problems that we end up never
actually getting out of this cycle which
is to say has existed for years i
welcome the fact that you know lorry
drivers are able to attract a better
salary and that's what we need including
better conditions as well and you know
99
of lorry drivers in this country are
white male average age 55
we we need to make this a more
attractive
industry to go into and and the solution
to that is to have those slightly higher
wages and better conditions at truck
stops and the like as well
um
these short-term visas these specialists
skilled worker visas ballerinas are on
the list and hgv drivers are not
well as i say
i wouldn't rule anything out here but
what i don't want to do is exactly but
that's absurd
yeah
but the difference here is that the real
problem that we face and we know this
because as soon as the tests become
available they are snapped up
immediately the real bottleneck in all
of this is testing that is where we need
to release it you've made the point as
far as that's concerned mr champs were
talking about bringing in drivers in the
interim to try and fix this problem
we're 110 000 drivers short there are
drivers 14 000 drivers went home during
the pandemic only 600 have come back by
any maths you know there's a good 10 000
even with slippage who could come back
and at least try to help in the short
term they can't get a skill worker uh
visa but a ballerina can
i should say those numbers are hotly
debated but i won't go into all of that
um what i would say is we've got six
million uh as i say eu settled and
pre-settled status many of those people
can already drive we've also got
hundreds of thousands of brits who are
able to drive and are being attracted
back so
we'll do whatever it takes as a setup
we'll move heaven and earth and i'll
look at any feasible scheme we've
already taken measures which have
doubled the number of tests available
including changing the law um so we're
using every lever uh at our disposal to
to do this uh you're gonna look at the
skill worker visa is that what you're
saying
absolutely not ruling anything out at
all we want to see this problem resolved
but i also want to see it resolve for
the long term not just a short term fix
which ends up exacerbating the long term
as well how many four courts were
affected this morning
well out of bp's uh 12 or 1300 for four
courts uh yesterday they told me that
five had to be closed throughout the
country and say there's no shortage of
vp that supplies fuel though
uh bp and um tesco the others morrisons
and uh asda and other supermarkets
saying they have no problems as have
other uh petrol companies so it has been
quite a defined problem this is not a
shortage of fuel at the refineries uh
and it's not something new in fact when
people don't matter if it is or not if
you can't get it from the refinery as
tony blair found out all those years ago
you can't get it from the refinery to
the forecourt it doesn't matter where
the problem is that was different
because they had massive numbers of uh
of hgv drivers not working there was an
actual strike there was a blockade it
was a very different situation but the
point is they couldn't get it from the
refinery to the forecourt that's a
similar going to be a similar problem if
we can't get more drivers my question to
you is transport secretary this morning
is how many four courts are affected
well as i say five yesterday on the bp
four courts the point i was going to
make though uh okay uh only five petrol
stations four courts in the whole
country that's impacted
of bp yesterday that's the case but okay
the point was going to be about the
others
let's clarify this point because you're
saying that there isn't an issue
all the front pages this morning are
saying that there is an issue the petrol
retailers association is saying that
there is an issue they're saying keep a
quarter of a tank in your um keep a
quarter of fuel in your tank just in
case you can't get any so all of these
people are wrong and you're saying
there's only five at petrol stations
affected
i want to answer this very precisely so
i appreciate it if you just give me 10
seconds to do that one i'm not saying
there's no issue there has been an issue
and that's what was reported on two the
conversations that were reported out and
are in today's paper are from over a
week ago and referred to the situation
over the previous three months so what
people can see is that although there
are stresses and strains in the system
by and large it had not impacted on
people's everyday life when it came to
filling up with petrol now what we need
to make sure is that we can continue to
have more people capable of driving and
therefore continue to alleviate the
problem or move heaven and earth to do
that how many petrol stations four
courts are affected this morning as
transport secretary you must know
so i'm afraid i don't have the answers
to that at seven a.m in the morning what
i can do what was it last night
as of last night five petrol stations on
bp network of 12 1300 were affected and
i'm meeting this morning with tesco and
i'm sure they'll give me the update for
themselves none of the other retailers
said that they had any closures
um how much is brexit to blame
well i've seen people point to brexit as
if it's the uh the culprit here in fact
they're wrong uh not only are there uh
very large and even larger shortages in
other eu countries like poland and
germany which clearly can't be to do
with brexit but actually because of
brexit i've been able to change the law
and alter the way that our driving tests
operate in a way that i could not have
done if we were still part of the eu so
brexit actually has provided part of the
solution of giving more uh slots
available for hgv tests and a lot more
twice as many tests available now than
before the pandemic a large proportion
of those i've only been able to do
because we're no longer actually in the
eu okay how are you feeling about civil
servants working from home um london
tech week conference uh yesterday sarah
healey um said that she enjoys working
from home she's a top mandarin so she
because she can spend more time on her
peloton exercise bike
well look i think we're in a world now
um where people where there is a
combination people were working from
home people are going into the office i
i had a look actually i know some the
last week for which i have numbers there
are about 1
300
uh transport official
civil servants in the
in the office i i i've been in this
weekend people are pleased to to come
back to the office there will be times
when people want to work from home we
are in this sort of transition um stage
through the uh through the autumn um and
uh and i i think things will settle down
into uh probably more of a hybrid world
but there's nothing like the spark of
being in the office um as as a lot of my
team found this this last week or two
although you find it very productive
being working from home don't you
minister can never get you in here can
we i'd be loving love to come and see
you
when when when when when oh well
as soon as you invite me on again okay
i'd like to okay we'll see you next week
i do find genuinely um that it's helpful
to be in the office there are times
where uh it's quite nice to be at home
when you're um on the radio first thing
okay um and on the tele box uh talk to
me about lateral flow test before i let
you go and there were some suggestions
that the pcrs would be replaced by
lateral flow tests when in time for
uh half term holidays for the kids i was
reading yesterday that there aren't
enough lateral flow tests and there
aren't enough people who will be able to
supervise those lateral flow tests via
zoom or whatever and so that's not going
to happen is that wrong
i don't think that's right this is my
colleagues over at the department of
health have been working very hard on
this and i know they've got the the date
of half term uh in mind
we did need to give the
producers of these things some time
because of course they've been busily
producing pcr tests over the summer um
to switch production to lateral flow um
but uh it looks to me like uh like
they'll be able to step up to that i
noticed actually in ireland um yesterday
uh that little came along with a pack of
uh which they're selling in their stores
in in in the republic there for 25 euros
and you get five lateral flow tests uh i
uh you know look forward to the
expansion of a lateral flow test perhaps
into supermarkets and elsewhere um as we
as we get on to the point where people
can buy those for returning from holiday
so you think a little uh lateral flow
test should be accepted as um currency
enough or does it have to be a little
bit more formal than that
well it will be for the department of
health to to set out the rules about how
people need to go about this but
remember with pcr tests uh you didn't
have to be
supervised as it were you had to get
that pcr test in advance you had to
record the fact that you ordered it uh
but you were then trusted to get on and
do it obviously the department of health
will put some guidance in place as to
how they want this to operate and
they're still working on that so i won't
tread on their toes but i i've every
confidence that the system will be gone
up and running uh in good time
but you're still uh hopeful that the
lateral flow
ruling will be in place for the
half-term holidays i i am as i say
they're working on the detail of this
and the the private market is having to
respond to
uh that shift to using lateral flows and
of course they need hundreds of
thousands even millions of them
available so and there's a there's a big
task for that but i say i know my
colleagues are working hard on that
okay the team will ring you later about
coming on next week in the studio thanks
very much for joining us i said next
week but i look forward to being there
okay